we are here in the East Room of the
White House it's incredible to be here
so much history has been made in this
room and this morning we're making
history here getting to talk with
President Trump and his top advisors
several members of President trumps
administration were sworn in in this
very room and that includes White House
chief of staff Reince Priebus who joins
us he was previously the longest-serving
chairman of the Republican National
Committee good morning mr. chairman
thank you for being here well it's a
very really neat and interesting and
cool place for you all to be here
accepting this show it's a it's a great
honor to be with you this morning
especially previous George Washington is
watching you right now
yeah pressures on I think that's the
only artifact that has been in the White
House and John and Abigail Adams is that
Gilbert Stewart painting of George
Washington here let's just look done Don
Hall assist made the moment that rent
Obama walked out here he tell us that
some of the button yeah that's right
let's talk about President Trump he has
signed 29 bills 32 executive orders he's
confirmed a Supreme Court justice the
next question is the big legislative
victory are you expecting a health care
bill this week
well I certainly hope so I I think so a
happy yeah well I think the mr. Capote
season I think I think we will I think
it will happen this week and so many so
much has been made of this signature
piece of legislation and the timing I
think it's important to know for the
listeners as well it just goes through
the house and the Senate this will be
the one that's one of the fastest pieces
of signature legislation to go through
for a president since Roosevelt I
believe and so people make so much of
the stimulus bill that the Barack Obama
put through but remember that was
pre-baked
in October during the financial meltdown
and people were rioting on both sides el
writing that bill passed in February but
other than that Bush 43 passed a bill in
June Reagan was in August
41 Bush 41 wasn't until a year and a
half later so this would be very quick
for president Trump to get this thing
through following up on that you have to
have tax reform by the end of the year I
think we'll have tax reform by the end
of the year yeah I think that's a goal
and I would expect it to happen Charlie
it is said that the presidency has been
changed by Dawn front and the presidency
has changed him how has he changed well
I don't I wouldn't say he's changed I
mean his views are the same and his
positions on Trade and the economy and
foreign policy are the same but I I do
believe he really I mean he talked about
NATO in a way that he doesn't he talks
differently about it today he talks
about China differently than he talked
about it during the campaign yeah okay
let's just take that for a second I mean
we'll get to the overall questions with
an important one but a NATO his
positions are saying that these
countries need to pay up and pay their
fair share you remember when the
Secretary General walked out onto the
podium right over there one of the first
things that came out of his mouth was
that President Trump is absolutely right
that it's about time that these
countries pay up so I would just say
this look at it a little bit differently
his positions are the same but his
positions are causing others that he's
speaking to to change their rhetoric and
their positions on matter look at
President Xi yes
president Trump has had a great
relationship with President Xi but
what's happening is President Xi is
using his positioning to leverage in
North Korea so I would just say his
positions are the same and his visions
are causing other people to change now
as far as the overall question I think
this is an enormous job and I think any
person in America I'm sure you all just
filming from here me sitting here taking
questions from here it sort of changes
you right I mean it sort of makes you
think about things a little differently
the enormity of decision making that
changes anybody and it has had a huge
impact on President Trump and thinking
about decision making you know there's a
lot of very intense conversation going
on around North Korea can you imagine a
scenario where President Trump and kim
jeong-hoon sit face-to-face and have a
conversation not right now I can't but
not right now I don't
you know I would unless the person was
willing to disarm and give up what he's
put in mountainsides across this country
and give up his dry for nuclear
capability and ICBMs but you know so the
question I think the answer is probably
not and I don't see that happening but
we're going to need a lot of cooperation
among the region and our leaders around
the world in order to get this person
under control with it but that'd be a
change in the tax reform but carried
interest III think you're probably going
to see that certainly the president's
position and as I said yesterday I think
that balloons going to get popped sooner
rather than later will be removed I
think if it was up to the president
would be gone
alright mine Cerebus will have to leave
it there but we thank you very much for
joining us at the table thank you for
having we appreciate it